good morning Hank it's Tuesday so if you
want to say I don't know in French which
is the only sentence of French I really
learned in three years of high school
classes you say jinnah say bah and both
the new and the PAS in that sentence are
negative because in French multiple
negatives affirm each other a phenomenon
called negative Concord which by the way
would be a pretty good tagline for the
social internet lots of languages from
Hebrew to Portuguese use negative
Concord but in English and some other
languages double negatives can actually
mean positives like to nose can equal a
yes sometimes of course it can't be
simple like let me give you an example
if you say in English I'm not not tired
that means you likely are tired and
potentially very tired because sometimes
double negatives are used to create a
kind of understatement on the other hand
you could feel something adjacent too
tired that isn't quite tired like the
weird feeling of being not not tired
late at night when your brain is
churning it can be very confusing like I
don't disagree generally means I do
agree but I'm not going nowhere
generally doesn't mean I'm going
somewhere so when I was a kid I always
thought that double negatives were
merely wrong in English because they
introduced confusion and needless
complexity but in fact they serve lots
of different purposes and even the most
like prescriptivists grammarian would
acknowledge that a sentence like I am
NOT disgruntled is grammatically correct
because it sounds ludicrous to say I am
gruntled but even in their more common
usages English double negatives can
offer a lot of richness and nuance like
consider the famous Pink Floyd lyric we
don't need no education we don't need no
thought control this is sung by a chorus
of school children in Pink Floyd's rock
album the wall and the kids are arguing
that they don't need education at least
not this rigid system of Education that
force feeds them certain values and
attempts to form all of them in two
identical bricks that can fit into a
vast wall and so in the lyric the kids
are rejecting the use of proper or
educated English by using a double
negative but their meaning is still very
clear and powerful which is the point of
language and that undermines the idea
that like proper English is somehow
superior to any other English language
is here to facilitate expression not
limited and these kids are rejecting a
system of Education that uses
language as another tool to enforce
uniformity and limit free expression in
the end language does shape thought and
so attempts to control language really
are forms of attempting thought control
and we don't need no thought control
which brings us at last tank to the use
of the double negative in another
classic rock and roll song smash mouths
all-star which includes the lyric didn't
make sense not to live for fun I think
the negatives here are meant to cancel
each other out so why didn't they just
sing it makes sense to live for fun well
for starters it doesn't fit the meter of
course but I think there might be
something else going on it makes sense
to live for fun is a present tense
statement about the right way to live a
human life it didn't make sense not to
live for fun is a past tense statement
about a failed way at living a human
life like all we know is that the
speaker tried one way of living for fun
and found that it didn't work that's not
the same thing as saying that their new
way of living does work and in that way
it didn't make sense not to live for fun
feels much more uncertain and conflicted
whereas it makes sense to live for fun
feels kind of naive now I think I'm not
gonna argue that all stars like a work
of rock opera genius or whatever it
obviously isn't but I do find that lyric
interesting all star does celebrate the
excitement of being thought of as an
all-star but it's also a little wary of
that excitement like I find it very
telling that in the handwritten first
draft of the song the lyric only
shooting stars break the mold originally
read wave bye-bye to your soul
in short I think all star might be a
song about celebrity written by people
who didn't not want Fame which isn't
quite the same thing as wanting it and
if that's the case didn't make sense not
to live for fun is a pretty great double
negative Hank I'll see you on Friday